I don't commit to a schedule I don't
have a work ethic I'm a really really
lazy person
don't continually change who you are in
an attempt to succeed people wanting to
be the best people the Orson Welles
personality I think that's cool
big motivation watch a top ten with
believe nation what's up it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack then chew
on today's lessons from a man who grew
up in Milwaukee and joined a number of
sketch troops to becoming a producer
actor voice actor and creator of the
animated series Rick and Morty he's Dan
Harmon and here's my take on his top ten
rules of success enjoy
alright let's stick things up with rule
number one my personal favorite find
what you love to do I don't commit to a
schedule I don't have a work ethic I'm a
really really lazy person I always tell
people to just follow your laziness
because laziness isn't people not
wanting to do something laziness is
people who are faced with having to do
something they don't want to do
everybody gets out of bed even on a
Saturday you eventually want to do
something so the best thing you can do
for yourself especially in a capitalist
democracy is find the thing that you
really like to do and try to figure out
how to turn that into your job I know
that that's a terrible advice in this
economy everyone has to go do stuff they
don't want to do but but I mean truly
that is the only way that I manage to
stay productive just by finding ways to
get paid to do the things that I would
rather do otherwise I'll just sit around
and play video games
rule number two is be yourself that's
the second piece of advice is figure out
what you love figure out who you are and
scream in your voice from your rooftop
and wait for people who want to hear you
to find you don't continually change who
you are in an attempt to
you know succeeded in wrangling an
audience just plant your feet and do
what you want to do more than anything
in the world because that's what you're
gonna be good at and that's what people
are gonna want to watch you do if you
said that means if you're a writer then
write how you want to write write the
shows that you that you would want to
watch on TV if you're a stand-up and
then don't don't emulate louis c.k
because he's not emulating somebody else
like he is being himself don't be as
angry as him don't be as sardonic as him
and lost you are anger you are sardonic
like be who you are and say the things
that you that would make you laugh if if
you if you heard them I guess and an
eventually sooner or later someone will
find you some ants will crawl across
your picnic blanket and they will the
pheromone trail will develop on people
you will find yourself before you know
it with an audience of some kind that's
that's the that's the emporia stuff I
think I think any artist is anybody that
makes anything even if you're making
chairs out of wood or walls I don't
wreck
your job is to is to leave this world
with your impression of it I think your
job is to is to remove the top of your
head and push something onto the top of
your brain that will leave an image of
an honest so that so that when you go
away there is some record that this is
how you perceived the world and
specifically you and that's your only
job it's the hardest job it's the
easiest job and whether you're a
stand-up a writer a carpenter I really
think you just have to be as honest and
transparent about how you viewed the
world as possible rule number three find
your definition of success how do you
define personal success did the amount
of misery that you take in versus put
out like like how much pain is coming in
and how much pleasure is going out to
other people it's like like a plant you
know just co2 and o2 like like like is
your account in the black Oh as far as
like so if somebody hurts you if
somebody punches you in the face and it
hurts like hell and you're really mad
you're an unsuccessful life if you then
go punch five people in the face because
you took in pain and caused five times
as much even if they're but yeah look if
you're John wick and all those guys are
like Facebook sure so look this there's
nuance there I guess that's why we love
those movies like the idea that you
could solve the world's problems by just
punching more people than you got
punched but but it but in reality so I
think success is defined by can you
actually convert when somebody punches
you in the face can you actually then go
put on a one-woman show about why did I
make it a woman just for the
face-punching
that I was like why don't you do that
thing where you switch pronouns like
like every other time the one you chose
unfortunate coincidence like if you get
punched in the face then you a woman I
thought I thought the phrase one-man
show would be so impressive like that's
the patriarchy like coming down what
it's a one-man show in my hypothetical
theatrical it never put out a one-man
show called I got punched in the face
and it's like people that go into it
that are having bad days who didn't even
get punched in the face or or or are
like fighting cancer or something that
they had come out going like I feel so
much better now that I saw that guys
show thank God he got punched in the
face that's success rule number four
work hard at your craft luck is where
preparation meets opportunity
somebody said but it's not just write
cliche it makes sense I think that's a
great way of yeah like it's it's because
you you never get to call yourself like
I don't know like you do what you do and
be good at what you do know what you
love doing and just keep doing it yeah
and if you die and nobody ever comes
along and says here's five dollars for
doing that then then you were you were
incredibly unlucky but you weren't
stupid you weren't a loser
so you you you you you were doing what
you love to do
yeah and I think and we all know people
who are way more lucky than talented but
if they're but it never lasts I mean it
doesn't it doesn't pay off you can't
just like have people shower you with
opportunity if you're not like working
hard rule number five is collaborate I
tend to get more work done faster if I'm
collaborating if I have someone
roped into my process that has a better
work ethic than me and and more fear of
failure than me and a committed that
could jostle me I go we got to get this
done by noon you know let's do this so I
I was always through because of fear and
ego I was never a good collaborator
until community's second season when I
really learned that I didn't have
anything to be ashamed of and that these
people were paid to help me and I
started working really in tandem with
other writers and the results were
really positive for me and I love that
process now I never thought I could be
someone who could sit in a room with ten
other people and just work together with
them where we're all equals and we all
just want to get one job done rule
number six get constructive feedback who
do you look to feedback before it gets
that stage like who do you look to when
you're in the process of it that's the
tough part it take your look at what
you're looking to your colleagues you
look to the writers you trust Ryan
Ridley and and Mike McMahan and Justin
roiland and everybody like everybody's
all in a room sardine together and
you're kind of trying to keep yourselves
from losing your minds by checking in
with each other is this funny is that
funny but it's hard because like you
can't it you'd be a bad TV writer if if
Dan Harmon are Justin roiland jumped up
and said oh this is going to be really
funny this is amazing this is amazing
and it was like like like well you're
not a great TV writer for saying shut up
sit down Harmon you know like no it's
not funny but you're also not maybe
doing the show a huge favor by
constantly only saying yep yep that's
true yep yep yep yep it's and but we're
all feeling that way so if you're at the
top then it's it's like what are you
supposed to do you know the answer is
like you self loves and you like open
the door for people to tell you you're
crazy but you also get mad if they do
and
oh boy yeah but it's you just kind of
collectively you hold yourselves hostage
you wait for Stockholm to set in and the
hope that that like creates a good idea
rule number seven is compete
I think ego and like people wanting to
be the best people the Orson Welles
personality I think that's cool and
really III encouraged like 25 year olds
to like inflate their egos as large as
they can and compete with each other
because they're doing it for the
audience the audience wins like that
that's the way it should be a bunch of
like you know creatives saying I'm the
best no I'm the best and I'm better than
you I'm better because they're like
gladiators and and there should be a
stadium of people around them winning
every every time rule number eight is
connect emotionally
why did community work there it's
sincerity I mean I I was as obsessed
with that show as any viewer could have
been so I think that previous to the
golden age of television what we're
calling now the the typical unfortunate
relationship was that because there was
so much money in TV and the audiences
were so large and the stakes were so
high there was almost an encouragement
for there to be a disconnect between the
people producing the shows and the
people watching them if you were good at
making TV if you were experienced it was
because you weren't really a viewer of
it you it was the part of you that
looked at it as that it's just a job so
in a strange ironic way the fact that I
didn't come up through the trenches for
instance as a staff writer I simply kept
writing pilots until one got turned into
a show that emotional immaturity that
sensitivity to the medium of television
is what got me in a lot of trouble and
also I think what made the show okay
rule number nine is just relax if you
could go back ten years and tell
yourself one piece of advice what would
it be or would you choose not to go back
no I would I would I would go back I
mean yeah zooming of the head I'm not
passing up an opportunity to like you
know to use that power the better way
way goodbye I wouldn't yeah if I could
just like call through
little toilet paper tube to myself at 34
I think I'd say you know it's it relax
something like that like like something
that's like I'd figure it out I'd go
like okay where was I at that time and
then like what do I really need to hear
it's like it's it's gonna be fine no
matter what you do but it which sounds
like a horrible complacent message for a
bit but it's me speaking to myself Matt
not saying you don't have it you don't
have a responsibility to contribute but
to say you need to let yourself off the
hook a little bit you're probably at the
end of the day just gonna screw a bunch
of stuff up and then also to like
accidentally make some good stuff and
then you get something your prostate or
something will just start killing you
like who cares if you're just an
animated skeleton with meat on it it's
gross sound advice I'd rule number 10
the last one before the bonus clips have
fun if you want to see some science
fiction that really makes sense you
should check out this movie I just saw
called the the astronaut in the bookcase
: interstellar it's based on a novel the
astronaut in the bookcase by Sapphire
it's like
oh it's a goodie that not since
nothing's the sequel to 2001 mmm have I
sat through people in space mr. [ __ ]
says he liked it because the science was
all right well I'm sure it was it seemed
pretty right to me yeah sure
Jesus Christ man not good you didn't dig
it yeah I was not into it
if you read the script for interstellar
you would not be you would that it would
not be a page-turner you would be like
when it's 20 pages and he's self yeah
what do you mean it looks like a smeared
bookcase oh it's back to the oh he's the
reason why the watch dumb I mean I yeah
I imagine that would be astounding if
when those things were happening in the
first two acts I wasn't constantly going
what then it would be amazing that it
all came back to this thing that made
you go what I'll be walking down the
street guy very sure is hard living on
earth in the apocalypse was all dry what
what what the hell what was that some
kind of silver entity just said Guba
Guba Guba
and then flew into the Sun it's moving
three hours later
whoa I'm changing I'm changing into
something I can't a Google gobble gobble
dooba
oh whoa there I am but that's me over
there oh god oh god oh god
oh I get it oh wow that's why the movie
was stupid cuz of me credits it's just
the way that she used
now I've got some special day in
Hartmann bonus clips for you guys but
before getting to that my question of
the day today is around his rule number
three find your definition of success I
want to know what a success mean to you
how do you define it leave in the
comments below I'm excited to see what
you have to say thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clips
when writing if you're stuck do you work
on something else is a creative change
of pace or powered through it it I mean
if you have the luxury of a deadline you
power through it or in my case you you
you masturbate until you get yelled at
the third time and then you power
through it if there's an addiction there
to adrenaline which is an unhealthy
workflow my advice that to stuck writers
who are on their own is to get unstuck
by proving how bad you are
stop stop trying to prove that you're a
good writer to yourself that's what's
probably got you stuck just want you to
share a little bit about how you got to
where you are today I was born white and
this wizard appeared on my porch one day
and said you get to write in TV because
of this and for no other reason and then
I was whisked away to a magical world
many of you don't know about where
opportunities grow on trees and we roll
around in them naked and just hit on
them and it's so fun and I'm so
untalented I remember being in first
grade there was a there was a bulletin
board that said the fruits of Labor the
teachers had made this cornucopia with
construction paper and it said what will
you be
and the orange said astronaut and the
watermelon said princess ordered
veterinarian or something and the banana
said author and that's the first time I
realized there was a word for this thing
that I loved doing which was you know
even before first grade even before
kindergarten I I was composing yeah I
was I was I was always writing little
stories and things giving them to my mom
and trying to get get praise from her
ever it seems like before I could speak
I was doing that do you think that you
need to be an [ __ ] to be successful
no I don't not at all I mean there's a
it almost seems the opposite doesn't it
do you successful is one thing good is
another I don't know a click that's
that's the big that's the big dichotomy
that we tend to enforce of we being
[ __ ]
is that oh he's successful because he's
nice but is he really talented don't you
really have to be an [ __ ] to be super
talented and IIIi don't think that I
don't believe that either no I don't I
don't think that I used to think that
you had to go to a dark place in order
to create because creation is
destruction and bla bla bla and like now
like that's just something that sickness
tells you because it wants to stay you
like it's in charge and it's like I
don't want to leave so what am I gonna
do I want you to go to therapy no I
don't
I'm your sickness I'll go away like but
the creativity is more just like getting
over your bullsh and like letting stuff
flow through you one way to do that is
to get so drunk and angry and and to
fall apart so much that you have nothing
left but what's coming through you
another way to do that is to breathe
four times or eat some yogurt or be in
love or take a vacation or play with a
choo-choo train or like have a house
take a week off and play some video
games I'd like leaders say it's the end
result is just like getting your ego out
of the way and letting flow through you
so you don't definitely don't have to be
an [ __ ] an argument could be made the
most important work ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]